foreign
welcome me back to CBS mornings as
Americans look for new ways to cope with
a very bumpy economy schools Nationwide
are just racking up debt to feed all
those hungry students the median
district has more than five thousand
dollars in lunch debt and that's
according to the school nutrition
Association in some areas unpaid
balances reach as high as 1.7 million
dollars so the skyrocketing costs are
just one of the many challenges Congress
ended a pandemic era program last fall
that paid for all student meals
regardless of income Meg Oliver has more
on this story she's been following it
Meg we got to feed the hungry kids
welcome thanks gal good morning our
research found student lunch dad doesn't
discriminate families earning less than
52 000 a year can apply for free or
reduced meals at school on our visit to
a Pennsylvania town we found a diverse
District where students live in mobile
homes and mansions and where
administrators are Fielding a growing
number of calls from parents who say
they can't pay
here you go what are you getting cutie
at Makefield Elementary a FIFA Benjamin
serves up cheeseburgers sweet peas and
hot dogs and baloney hanging a few
lyrics for the lunch crowd I drive an
hour every day to get here that's how
important these kids are family to me
the Pennsbury School District in Yardley
Pennsylvania has more than 9 000
students 30 percent qualified for free
or reduced School meals our kids coming
through this lunch line with trays full
of food and no money in their account
yep that happens a lot yes it does the
federal waiver is providing free school
lunches Nationwide during the pandemic
expired in September you guys want
cheese a new study shows School Meal
programs are at risk with Rising costs
and supply chain issues
how high is your student lunch debt at
the moment it's 65 000 why is it so high
I think families are having to decide
whether they are going to pay their
electric bill or pay for their students
to eat meals Kimberly Steffy is the
director of financial services for the
district they're fortunate to have
private donors pay their debt allowing
them to continue providing breakfast and
lunch to every student even if they
can't afford it I imagine you're one of
the lucky districts yes absolutely so if
you're a district that doesn't have
these great donations coming in what
happens those districts will have to
take resources from their general fund
to pay for the debt Nationwide student
launched at tops 19 million dollars some
districts are so desperate they've
resorted to lunch shaming in the past
offering kids a cold sandwich instead of
a hot meal or Banning them from school
events if they carry a balance Lori
Atkins is president of the school
nutrition Association who's urging
Congress to permanently pass free School
meals for every student there are
definitely some kids that are going
hungry because the families aren't
applying for benefits and then other
families just aren't qualifying for the
program because their wages may have
gone up and it bumps them out of the
qualifications we've got lower
participation and higher costs and we're
really concerned about making sure that
all hunger kids have access to food
during the school day what is your
biggest fear that costs will continue to
increase and that our reimbursement
rates will be lowered the current
federal program pays schools back for
each student meal served based on income
levels as part of a bipartisan Bill last
summer Congress raised the reimbursement
rate by 40 cents for lunch but the
program is set to expire in June okay
pound it out would you ever be able to
turn a child away who was hungry no just
like turning your family away do you
think Congress realizes how many
students go hungry every day no no
somebody need to let them know what's
your message to them every kid needs to
get fed
Benjamin
according to the USDA more than 9
million children in America are food
insecure in the past few years has only
pushed that number higher recent efforts
for a more permanent solution appears
stalled in Congress and the latest
proposal doesn't go back to paying for
all student meals so districts are going
to have no choice at the end of this
year to dip into their general fund I
like that lunch lady what's her name
FIFA Benjamin who's going hot dogs and
baloney because most of us take school
lunches for granted right and we should
not do that and put this just to put
into perspective that District they're
in debt about sixty five thousand
dollars the average teacher salary is
around sixty five thousand dollars so
they could add another teacher yeah
that's right I mean and public you have
to make a choice you shouldn't have to
make a choice public education is part
of the promise of America it's important
to learn and you can't learn on an empty
stomach absolutely uh it's a great
report Meg thank you very much plus I
don't know about you on an empty stomach
I tend to get cranky how about you
fruity crank how about you Nate a little
hangry there